vous connaissez tous l'application waze
le gps intelligent aujourd'hui à
l'application s'ouvre collectivités
locales c'est une première en ile de
france il est testé ici à versailles
grand parc et notamment à versailles il
est mis en application depuis à quelques
jours je suis avec gillot days la
responsable alors pourquoi avoir mis en
place ce dispositif à versailles
versailles 8 millions de visiteurs qui
viennent visiter le château annuellement
plus un certain nombre de personnes qui
transitent en fait sur la commune de
matin pour venir travailler ou le soir
il nous semble important en fait de
pouvoir communiquer mieux auprès de la
population qui ne consultent pas
forcément les médias traditionnels
d'information comme les sites web de la
ville donc wait du coup était pour nous
la bonne solution pour leur dire
attention il ya des travaux vous allez
avoir du mal à circuler aujourd'hui dans
la commune j'ai l'application dans ma
poche je n'ai pas besoin de télécharger
une autre application pour tester le
dispositif rien du tout c'est uniquement
dans wilde nos données sont remontés
elles sont indiquées ville de versailles
et donc quand les travaux ont lieu elles
apparaissent avec le label ville de
versailles
donc elles sont fiables bon je crois
qu'ils brassent qu'une seule chose à
faire tester le dispositif
on va à présent tester l'application
waze dans les rues de versailles avec
notre voiture
je vais rentrer à ma destination à
versailles
on peut voir là actuellement voilà les
bouchons qu'il y a on peut voir
également un petit voilà ça veut dire
travaux aux zones de travaux avenue du
général-de-gaulle à versailles ce sont
des informations données par la
municipalité
voilà on peut voir qu'il y actuellement
voilà une pelleteuse un camion tout est
indiqué les travaux voilà pas de
surprises en tout cas avec wyse
il n'y a aucune surprise maintenant à
versailles
voilà c'est terminé on a pu voir que
l'application waze fonctionner avec la
communauté d'agglomération de versailles
grand parc
il ya une seule commune pour l'instant
qui équipés et bientôt il y aura 18